- All right, so the previous presentations
have all looked really
slick and really nice.
I thought I'd mix it up with something
that you didn't even know
someone could as a presentation,
which is, you guess it,
a series of screen shots.
But I have a moderate reason for this.
I wanna show some student
generated content,
but I wanted to make it anonymous,
so I really tastefully
blurred some things out.
You will notice when it happens.
Let's see, this is, make it bigger.
It did it, yes it did.
I taught MATH 230 and 231,
those are a first year
sequence of courses.
It's a very intense course for people
who are usually first years
and they are rather sure
they wanna do math and they're definitely
right about to do a lot of it.
Success in this course and
the major more generally
is usually highly correlated with
if you're able to form study
groups in the first year,
if you're able to find
people you like to work with.
Sort of at university, the students
are the most important
part of the whole thing
and students working
with students is one of
the most important things the
students can be doing here.
One of my main goals
was to try to figure out
how to get students working
together, how to get students
kind of all buying into
this idea of a community.
What I did was I had a Canvas page
and let's see what we got.
It's got a syllabus, boring things.
This is gonna be the page for both 230,
which I did in the fall and also 231,
which is finishing up now.
I'll kind of mix and
match those two pages.
One thing that I got is some assignments,
which are assignments.
The first thing I thought the Canvas page
should be is useful to the students,
before I can get them to
use some of the content
that'll presumably help
them form connections
or help them get more out of the course.
I thought I'd meet them where they're at
and make it something that
they actually wanna do.
So assignments are
something they have to do.
Usual assignments, they
can click on things,
see what the assignments are, usual stuff.
I also have files, which I've
got oodles of stuff in here.
We've got assignments, also,
tech files for the assignments,
which just helps them type up their stuff.
It's content, what else
do got in here, though?
We got course notes, which is
now something that they like.
Students like course
notes, as it turns out.
It's something that at
least gets them here.
I have got a couple flavors.
So course notes are sort of a bridge
between students being
there and then something
that they can see on
Canvas where they say,
"Oh yeah, that's something
that I kind of interacted with.
"At least I was present
during the creation
"of those course notes."
It's a step, it's a step.
Here's whatever the heck this day is
and yup, those are the course notes.
I was in the TEAL room
which I do recommend,
it's a good room.
Course notes, they flip
through and see whatever it is.
Some days I did, whatever these are,
these presentations which look
nicer, nicer than this one.
Oh yeah, cats.
If you have a prime number of cats,
you should do abstract
algebra with your cats,
(audience laughter)
it's highly recommended.
Anyway, gimmicks to kind
of get the students in.
When it starts getting more personal,
more things they care
about, more communal,
is maybe announcements
and then I'm gonna hit up
my favorite, which was the Piazza feature.
Announcements, you can do routine stuff,
like hey, here's study materials.
Or, hey, here are office hours.
Or, here's reading more
if you were curious
about that thing, you
can jump real in depth
and here's stuff if
you're curious about it.
Or for me, the always
thing that I need is,
here's the things I lied
about today, sorry about that,
and here's how to correct
those course notes.
But then you can get some other
interesting announcements.
Like, hey everybody,
there are free t-shirts
that you can get.
Here's one of these math t-shirts.
That's suddenly something
that I'm using the course
not to necessarily
distribute course content,
but instead to sort of sell the package
of the social community.
What do I got here, I've got shirts.
Here's me advertising an
event that was happening.
That was a cool event, a one woman play
about being a woman in
math, would recommend.
Next I wanna talk about is Piazza.
Piazza is, if you don't
know it, it's a feature
which is an external tool
that can plugin to Canvas.
The idea is students can
post things, it's a forum.
Students post, they can
post things anonymously
so they can say, hey
everybody, I'm really confused
about what happened
today, but I don't wanna,
you know, slap my name on there
and maybe I don't wanna go
to office hours 'cause I
don't know, it's whatever,
two o'clock in the morning
and they just wanna know
the answer without leaving
the buttery or whatever.
So they can post stuff
and you can get students
posting questions, hey, what
the heck's going on here?
And then another student can answer,
oh, I think this is what's going on here.
The instructor can say, yep,
that's what's going on here
or the instructor can make it more nuanced,
well, actually, maybe
you wanna consider this.
You can edit everything.
Students can go back and forth.
You can also generate,
so I use this to generate
not just questions that the students ask,
but also here's me, I
started doing a thing
where students will post
their solutions to homework
because it was partly
born out of laziness.
I didn't wanna write
up homework solutions.
And partly, it doesn't
sound like a bad idea.
Students post their own solutions.
Here's a solution I did for problem four,
well here's my solution to problem six.
And they can do this anonymously
and then they can read off
each other, they can learn,
they can see other ways to
approach the same thing.
More ways to sort of build this community.
This was motivated by, I
gave them too much homework
and then I said, and if you want,
you can not do one of
those homework problems
if you do one of these,
so it's a little carrot.
Similarly, they can
post their course notes.
Here's my notes for the
day, well here's my notes,
and well, here's my notes.
It's the same sort of a thing.
They can be all anonymous.
You can collaborate, you
can make shared files.
Is Piazza the tool for this?
I don't know, that's what we did, though.
What else do I got here?
Study materials for the
exams, here's study materials.
And oh, here's my study materials.
Here's my detailed study
guide, oh great, cool.
Students are doing a lot of stuff.
But then, they also started
using it for fun course stuff
like one GroupMe to rule them all.
That way they can all collaborate
and get all on the same page
or whatever, if they want.
So it started out with more Piazza
as routine questions and answers,
but you can use it to generate more,
I don't know, more nuanced interactions.
You can use it to then
ultimately have students
as a communal message board or something,
which I think really helps
with the buy in, which is key.
That's all I got.
If you've got any questions,
I'm happy to answer any.
- [Female Attendee] How often
do you monitor Piazza, you?
Do you get notified every
time a new post is made?
- The question was how often
I get notified about Piazza.
That's in a setting.
I can get daily notifications if I want.
I can get notifications every
time something's posted.
I can probably turn off
notifications all together.
Me, I have them about,
I think I have them set
to whenever they get posted.
Like the day before an
exam, everyone's posting
their study materials
and their study guides
and whatever it is, so I get a lot
of notifications then
and I just ignore them.
But usually, it's a
question like, hey Pat,
I'm pretty sure there's an
egregious error in your homework
and problem four should be
something drastically different.
I read it and I say, well
that's correct, yeah.
I've gotta change that.
So those I can respond to
immediately if I feel like it.
- [Female Audience Member]
So you basically look at it
every day, you personally?
- I got nothing else to do.
(audience laughter)
Question in the back?
- [Woman] Hi Pat, that
was a great presentation.
I have a question about the extent
to which your efforts to
build community drew in
the students who aren't
traditionally represented in math.
Did you see that happening?
- That is something that
I very much care about.
It's hard for me to compare,
how engaged a student
would be otherwise, but
for instance, it's a
two semester sequence.
There's usually a big drop
off between the first semester
and the second semester
because students decide
this isn't for me or I
didn't make any friends
in the first semester,
so I'm just gonna leave.
Disproportionately, that's females,
non-binary students, people of color.
It really disproportionately
affects them historically
and that's not a Yale thing,
that's just a STEM thing.
Maybe just an academics
thing, I don't know.
This year there wasn't
so much of a drop off.
The percent of, the
demographic representation
at the beginning of the first semester
is very close to what it is
at the end, so that's a plus.
There are a couple things that might be
contributing to that but something
I'm keeping in mind, yes.
Yeah?
- [Female] Just a little
bit on the philosophy
behind posting their
solutions for the homework,
which sounds amazing to me and
I will definitely adopt that.
How do you go about, is it right after
they submit their own problem sets
or how do make sure to
maintain the integrity?
- Yeah.
The integrity of it all
is, a big level is trust.
I post things, the homework problem itself
is something that they could look up
without trying too hard.
Something that they can just
Google letter for letter
and something close enough
will pop up that they can solve
and they can just copy if they wanted to.
Having students post homework
solutions isn't so much of a,
oh now they can suddenly cheat.
In my class, they could do
that if they wanted to anyway.
Plus, I strongly encourage
collaboration anyway.
So students who wanna
work together already do
and they just at the
top of their homework,
they say, I collaborated with
so-and-so, the other person.
But yeah, ultimately I
just kinda trust them.
I think that's working out for me.
The exams and such are on
par with the homework grades,
so that's an indicator
that something's happening.
Yeah?
- [Male Attendee] So
we've seen that Canvas
supports Cyrillic and Arabic,
does it support math notation?
- It does, it does
to various degrees of success.
Let's see if I can
magically find one that had,
there we go, beautiful.
This one,
actually, it is what
it is, I'm pretty sure
that's the feature that they have.
It supports latex, which if
you've ever tried to type math
in a computer before,
that would be the thing,
if anything, you might try to use.
And yes, it does support
that, you have to just
type double dollar signs or something,
and it just kind of automatically works.
So that's convenient.
You could also copy and
paste if you're so inclined.
(audience applause)
( music)